what about technology there's like the
dark ages are completely encompassed by
this
middle ages period
what about technology because it feels i
don't know this is me talking as the guy
that doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking don't know what he's talking
about most of the time but specifically
when it comes to the history of the
planet that i live on and
i don't see
it feels like rome had a lot sorted
and then you come out the other side at
the renaissance
and we've got
what have we got to show for it like
some art
some castles which you have profited
from massively
and
no i
don't presume
and
some death some plagues like
is no one adventuring or technologying
during this period what's happening
well there's no doubt that the roman
empire had um achieved a sort of
technological spike in the graph if you
like
um
[Music]
very inventive and ingenious
age
underpinned of course by
mass slavery
and one of the reasons that
certain societies have been able to
build
fast and high and impressive and large
is because they've enslaved uh tens of
that you know ancient egyptians aliens
aliens like the egyptians enslaved yes
yes yes of course i've forgotten about
that um
so
but you know there's no no so after the
breakup of the roman empire in the west
there's no doubt that you see
all sorts of networks broken
uh over what used to be the western
roman empire
some of those are knowledge networks and
some of those are technological exchange
networks and some of those
they just
are wealthy networks
so it takes a long time
for
certainly western europe and i'm i'm
being quite specific about western
europe to recover
uh to a point of of
similar technological sophistication but
it doesn't take as long as you're
suggesting when do you think that is
when do they get back to
i mean whether it's it's about getting
back to par but getting back to a um
a society that is
uh becoming
that is every generation seems to
becoming wealthier and more creative and
more inventive and more
thirsty for knowledge and more capable
of deploying that knowledge to useful
ends
it's around the millennium that you you
start to see
technology new technology starting to
transform the way that people live let's
let's take
one small example we talked earlier we
didn't really talk earlier we mentioned
earlier nights
if you take
the stirrup
and the arrival the importation of
stirrup technology from
east to west
when 8th century maybe 9th century
sometime like this it takes a while to
arrive and to spread but certainly by
the millennium the stirrup
people are riding the stirrups i think
in the 12th century it's just part of
iran in fact you couldn't have nights
without stirrups because you couldn't if
you think about
um trying to joust on horseback you
should give him the lance you're gonna
need a couple of things on the horse
you're gonna need a saddle
right
and you're gonna need stirrups because
otherwise if you ride that horse at
something and try and jabba that lance
what's going to happen is the horse will
go that way and you will go that way
and it will be comical until you break
your pelvis on your full
it will still be comical but not for you
uh
so
the
invention of the stirrup enables us
a military revolution because it enables
the development of frankish cavalry and
frankish cavalry to take one example are
a
central part of the success of the first
crusade now the first crusade
we could argue as a transformative
political
uh event in the history of the whole
middle ages but
although this sounds a bit butterfly
effect the first crusade might not have
been possible without the invention of
the stirrup which seems to us an
impossibly simple piece of technology
but it is very important
and from that point you know from around
the 10th 11th century you start to see
in western europe
um
inventions you know windmills windmills
sound kind of boring but they they
they're incredibly important for the
development of agriculture
i see a rising population which is able
to feed itself better because you have
um
you know you have improvements in plow
technology these are unglamorous things
but you know agricultural technology
improves military technology improves
um so it's earlier than you think that
the difference starts to be made the
astrolabe comes back into society
or comes into you know western society
from uh from the greeks and the arabs
and that makes navigation a lot easier
what about warfare any warfare
technology developments
well by the 14th century students in
gunpowder
i mean that's i mean gunpowder is a sort
of end of the middle late middle ages
end of the middle ages kind of
phenomenon and we tend to associate the
arrival of gunpowder on the battlefields
with
the end of the middle ages but um it's
it's there quite early on in the again
in the west
uh
in
in in the late middle ages so um and
then in armor technology yeah look you
see
armor and arms i mean
think about
the example
frankish swords frank's extremely famous
for uh for producing high quality swords
um
what was so high quality about them
what'd they do
well no it doesn't shatter on impact
mainly
um
capable of maintaining a sharp a sharper
edge
uh
if you think about the development of
armor between i mean think about the
norm close your eyes think about the
tapestry as i uh i say to all my lovers
um
and what are they wearing like
male lincoln it's
the political terms chainmail that's
tautology but you know male armor
uh the development of that to by the
14th century largely plate armor enables
um
heavier fighting
closer at hand on foot and
bigger armies required longbow
technology
lots of developments that seem seem
quite primitive to us because we we're
in a nuclear age and we're post
the barbed wire machine guns the
trenches but
technological and then you mentioned
navigation well
again by the early 15th century you've
got boat technology and navigation
technology improving to the point that
you know two generations before columbus
sailed for the uh for the indies and
bumped into the americas
um and henry the navigator
and portuguese sending
trips ever further down the west african
coast
and coming back it wasn't the problem
wasn't going down because it was coming
back
so
but long before that even if you look
around the turn of the millennium to go
back to sort of where i started
uh you've got europeans in the americas
but vikings over at lanza meadows
around the year 1000.
so medivh technology is
is more sophisticated than perhaps we
give it credit
um
yeah it's a weird one because the way
that technology works it
enables further developments to be made
so you do have this sort of exponential
curve that comes in as something gets
enabled then that enables something else
that goes down there and it kind of
feels like
where you're leaving the story whatever
1500 in a bit
that
there's a lot of
the
fundamental pieces in place
to allow pirates within 300 years to
allow
bigger buildings to allow faster
development
faster travel so on and so forth more
dangerous weapons
um well okay but let's take those in
turns pirates
they've always been pirates
um but they've been able to travel as
far across the ocean where they've been
able to do
depends how far you don't need to travel
very far to be a part i mean if you look
at uh
caribbean obviously that's where jack
sparrow is yeah like you've just watched
too many movies that's that's the
problem yeah yeah because they've been
the pioneers the pirates the pirates of
the mediterranean there's a story that
you could set in any bloody age
really
pirates of the mediterranean that's what
this thing is yeah it sounds like you
know they're fighting over pastors
making pirates of the mediterranean
fighting over pasta that's what they
could have had
okay keep it up
what was the next thing you said i was
about to demolish
buildings big big buildings yes
buildings
lincoln cathedral lincoln cathedral
halfway between you
biggest building in the world mate for a
while it was bigger than the period yeah
until the spire blew down but that was
bigger than the great pyramid
giza it's on a big hill isn't it
and it was the uh yeah but we're not
counting the hill
it's even better because on the top of
the hill
put the [ __ ] eiffel tower on top of a
hill
and count the hill
oh man
the dome of the rocks big isn't it what
oh it's on a hill
it makes it look bigger well everyone's
done that everyone's everyone's pulled
something down around something that
they're trying to make look bigger to
create the illusion that the thing that
they're trying to make look bigger
actually is bigger you're talking about
manscaping
uh manscaping
i wasn't actually aware was a specific
term although man's skateboard support
manto manscaping
no
like shaving your cubes yeah but i mean
i didn't know that it was like a pursuit
that people went into is there like a
subreddit for it
i don't know there's like a peloton
class for you just click the button
that's next to yoga manscape thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace
you